Salut à tous
Je vous envoie cette vidéo
en direct des Îles Canaries
où j’ai commencé à prendre en charge
les problèmes de la France
parce que, clairement,
c'est la galère partout en ce moment
et je pense que chacun peut faire
un petit geste pour que la France
soit un pays plus agréable à vivre
chacun peut y mettre du sien
et de mon côté, j’ai commencé ma partie du travail
alors, clairement, y a encore
des petites résistances par-ci par-là,
mais honnêtement
j’ai la situation bien en main
Espèce de tarée, va !
Espèce de tarée !
T’as essayé de me tuer !
Non… Non j’ai pas essayé de te tuer
Tu m’as foutu dans le sable
j’arrivais plus à respirer !
n’importe quoi, on jouait à cache-cache
allez retourne dans ton trou !
c’est pas ça les règles du cache-cache, Laura !
quand on joue à cache-cache,
on se cache volontairement,
on nous met pas dans un trou à 3m de profondeur
contre notre gré, en chantant «libérée, délivrée»
N’importe quoi y a pas 3m de profondeur
t’exagères toujours
ah oui c’est grand
Ah bah oui c’est grand
Bon beh ok, j’ai essayé de te tuer
voilà, t’es content ?
Ben non je suis pas content Laura !
Tu croyais quoi franchement ?
Qu’il y aurait pas d’enquête ?
Comment tu comptais maquiller ça ?
Je comptais rien maquiller Guillaume !
ce qui est suspect c’est pas que tu meures
ce qui est suspect
c’est chaque seconde où t’es en vie !
puis je sais pas,
je voulais faire une bonne action pour la France
la France va mal
on arrive pas à se débarrasser du Covid
y a plein de virus qui arrivent
je voulais aider le système sanitaire
Mais je suis pas une maladie !
T’es pas non plus le symbole de la bonne santé
J’ai échappé au Covid moi, madame
alors que personne n’y croyait !
Oui, hé ben, c’est injuste,
mais parfois faut se sacrifier, Guillaume !
La France a perdu beaucoup d’argent
avec la crise sanitaire
on peut pas continuer comme ça à t’entretenir
juste parce que t’as pas les capacités
d’exercer un vrai travail !
Mais je fais le même travail que toi !
Non… non… moi je suis plus dans…
dans l’écriture des textes, dans les mots d’esprit
dans l’analyse des contextes socio-culturels…
Toi t’es, t’es…
toi t’es plus dans le visuel, toi
enfin, joue pas sur les mots
t’as très bien compris ce que je voulais dire !
Ce que je comprends surtout
c’est que t’as trouvé un super bon prétexte
pour venir te la couler douce aux Canaries
alors que la France est en train de crever !
Pardon mais il a pas fallu longtemps
pour te convaincre de venir avec moi
Alors là, ça n’a strictement rien à voir !
moi je l’ai fait pour une raison
complètement altruiste
Ah bon laquelle ?
Je pensais te voir en maillot de bain, figure-toi
en quoi c’est une raison altruiste ça ?
Parce que j’aurais fait des photos
que j’aurais envoyées aux copains !
Au lieu de ça, ça fait 3 jours
qu’on est sur cette plage de merde
j’ai pas vu un nichon
et en plus, j’ai failli crever !
Oui ben c’est l’histoire de ta vie ça,
t’es né, t’as failli crever,
tu manges une escalope, t’as failli crever,
tu te fais anesthésier pour une opération banale,
t’as failli crever !
Y a pas un jour qui passe sans qu’on me dise
« Guillaume Bats a failli crever»
Pourquoi ça marche jamais ?
Tu sais ce que je pense, Guillaume ?
Je pense que t’es le diable, en fait
je pense que personne peut se débarrasser de toi
t’as la vie qui s’accroche à toi
telle une mauvaise herbe à un tronc d’arbre
t’es immourable Guillaume Bats !
bien sûr que si, je suis mourable !
Non tu meurs jamais !
T’es éternel comme les méduses !
Ah ouai ?
Tiens là, par exemple,
je vais dans l’eau, je suis sûr que je me noie !
Non tu mourras pas !
Mais bien sûr que si !
Hé ben vas-y je te regarde !
Ok ! Regarde bien, parce que je reviendrai pas !
Hé ben je te regarde !
Adieu Laura !
Adieu alors !
Ouai ouai
N’importe quoi
"Ah tu peux pas mourir Guillaume"
Ben tu vas voir si je peux pas mourir !
Espèce de tarée, va !
N’importe quoi elle !
Allez hop, c’est parti !
Je vais mourir !
Qu’est ce qui s’est passé ?
Je sais pas
T’as eu un élan d’humanité envers moi ?
j’en sais rien
Bah je crois que c’est ça hein
non je crois que c’est...
c'est ma conscience écologique
qui a pris le dessus
on jette déjà tellement n’importe quoi dans la mer
alors par égard pour les poissons
j’ai pas voulu en rajouter
Donc en fait, tu m’as sauvé
par solidarité poissonnière quoi…
ouai
les poissons, les crustacés
les petits planctons
d'accord… c’est déjà ça de pris
les araignées de mer
ouai
les castagnoles
c’est des petits poissons des mers chaudes
ok… ben merci hein
ben de rien
allez
maintenant montre-moi un petit bout de nichon